i think in a funny way i didn't i didn't
find a film i think the film found me
i i made a lot of short films i started
making films at a very young age i i
made my first shot at 19
and
um after making a lot of shorts
i went to film school twice
in 2010 i i knew i've made a lot of
shots it's time to make my first feature
film
i'm not like some directors that you
know they've got lots of ideas in their
head and they would just pitch like 10
ideas and producers to go like yeah
let's do that you know for me you know i
need to be obsessed by something
how did the obsession begin
there was there was a period of time
when a lot of childhood memories just
came
flooding back into my head i think in
singapore you spend most of your time
sort of like growing up chasing grades
becoming an adult you know starting a
career and that
your childhood sort of gets swept
underneath the carpet you know i think
it's been repressed for so long
and all these memories just came back
and and i remember you know that we had
this filipino woman you know um who
worked with us for eight years she came
when i was four
she left when i was 12. um
her name is
um so it really started from there i
think that that one
it really started from one emotion when
i was 12 and
we were sending her off at the airport
and i remember
i was just crying and crying and crying
and it was so painful
and it was that recollection that really
made me ask a lot of questions like how
is it that a child can be so attached to
someone
you know who's who's not part of who you
are you know she she's not family she's
a stranger she's a servant um you know
yeah you're not connected by blood so it
it really started from there
is it common for uh filipino nannies to
uh raise children in middle to lower
middle class families
i think in in countries like singapore
or even like and hong kong and very
developed asian economies um it's a very
pragmatic
sort of thing to have to employ a mate
from
the philippines or from indonesia i
wouldn't say you know like in the west
having a mate is a very bozoir idea
usually it's a very middle class upper
class thing but but in singapore it's
very much because of economic reasons
because very pragmatic reasons you've
got a very huge middle class we have got
a lot of dual income families white
collar working parents and
for them to bring the bread and butter
someone has to look after the kids so it
was it's it's a very practical decision
to employ me it's not because the family
is ridiculously rich it's just because
you know
you just need to have someone the film
itself the script itself took two years
you know i don't actually find structure
i don't actually find
um setups and payoffs you know so easily
for me i have to go on the journey of
the characters
i slowly discover what i'm trying to say
you know um
what what is it that i wanna um i wanna
express in this film
can you tell us about the challenges you
faced in casting jolly i mean the the
heart of this film is this young boy had
he acted before how did you find it no
he was he has a complete fresh face
hasn't been in theater hasn't been on
film hasn't been on tv it hasn't even
been in the school play
i knew i wanted um because i'm very very
wary of actors
child actors that have gone through a
lot of training because i wanted
something very honest i wanted something
very organic i wanted something very
natural
so
we started a very long casting process
it was a very rigorous process we took
about 10 months
in those 10 months we went to about 20
schools in singapore we saw about 8 000
children
out of the 8 000 children we saw
we formally auditioned about 2000 of
them
and then
we shortlisted 150
and i spent about six months
uh every saturday and sunday doing
workshops with these kids
so it was it was like a reality show
where
where we were eliminating like 150 down
to six months later we have like the top
ten what scene did they
it wasn't about scenes for me it's about
finding out who these people really are
and i think a lot of times there might
be kids that sparkle on a day
but but if you're gonna be holding a
film if you're gonna be filming for like
25-30 days you need someone who's
consistent with someone who who has real
presence
um and i wanted to see if if if the kids
could deliver that
this boy and his real name is jala
you know i actually renamed the
character of the of the boy after i
found him because tiana in chinese chia
means family and love means happiness
and when i was when when i when i casted
him i was thinking
wow that's great irony for this film
because
it's really about a family that's not
very happy
yes and the boy's name is like happy
family
i think most filmmakers like to like to
go for
the cutest kid
the one with the smiley face the one
that
you know that you want to hug and kiss
and all that but he's not he's not the
prettiest of kids but there's something
about his face there's a
there's a fragility
and there's a fracture there and and
it's something you can't quite describe
you just know
something is not quite right with this
kid but you can't say what you know my
philosophy is that we're all trying you
know as people as humans we're all
trying to be the best of what we can
we all want to be
good workers good parents uh good
fathers good mothers we all try to be
the best but we can't because we're
imperfect and our flaws are underway you
know because there's gluttony and
there's greed and there's lust and all
of that so so if you look at my
characters
they're always trying
they're always trying but they'll never
get there and it's not really their
fault you know because because that's
what we are it's i think that's that's
when you have drama that's when you have
cinema it's because of our imperfections